[Musique]
c'est un domaine de 9 hectares de
plantations qui conserve soigneusement
les plantes indigènes et endémiques et
exotique de la réunion pendant les
vacances on continue à proposer des
visites guidées à 11 heures alors la
collection réunion les espèces indigènes
et en dégoût que c'est la collection
femme et tente rares qui ont quasiment
disparu de l'ouest de l'île
et puis ensuite pour les vacances en
propose la collection plantes longtemps
et à l'intérieur et les épices donc
c'est toujours par rapport à pierre
poivre et sinon on peut faire aussi le
verger ou encore les palmiers ou sur la
famille de chateauvieux puisque c'est
son ancienne demeure agricole mascarin
jardin botanique se dévoile le long de
ses sentiers arpentant les huit
collections végétales du domaine et pour
les vacances ce sont les épices que
découvre le public
un hommage ou trois centième
anniversaire de la naissance du
botaniste pierre poivre le roma est là
tout l'été avec des jardinières à
l'intérieur il ya les épices ensuite on
propose
un jeu de tests de senteurs avec des
feuilles toujours en relation avec les
épices et puis une plantation des pis
[Musique]